hey gq i'm trevor noah and i'm going
undercover
on the internet
[Music]
this is actually me
i uh i locked it again i'm sorry man no
worries you don't mess around with your
security you close that laptop and it is
password time immediately most people
are like five minutes you're like nah
as soon as i close it i want this thing
to be locked forever
you don't waste any time first up
wikipedia sometimes i like to say this
wikipedia
just to keep things interesting at the
time of his birth
his parents interracial relationship was
illegal under apartheid law
and noah highlights this in his
autobiography interracial sexual
relations and marriages were not
decriminalized until a year after noah's
birth
when the immorality act was amended in
1985.
this is correct but the immorality act
in south africa was
a law that made it illegal
for people of different skin colors to
have sex so if you're a different race
from somebody else you did not engage
with sexual uh and
sexual relations with them uh this was
something that was
frowned upon because then you make
babies like me
posted imdb
he is a polyglot what he speaks english
khasa zulu sutru turana tonga
afrikaans and some german wow that seems
excessive
i understand kosa i don't speak it
fluently
uh my mom just i don't know she just
spoke to me and i don't i don't know why
i never learned it that's weird
i don't really think i speak such i
speak to anna more than i speak suits
about suit and drawing are pretty much
the same or similar so yeah this is this
is mostly true and then
some german depending on how sober i am
next when he was young trevor was thrown
out of a minibus by his mother because
she thought the driver from another
tribe
was trying to kill them wow who wrote
this why would you rise it like this
i think it's more trevor and his mother
jumped out of
a minibus to save their lives that's
what happened there this makes it seem
like my mom just threw me out and then
she carried on the journey
and then we met after us and i was like
what happened mom and she's like oh yeah
my bad
i was a little paranoid he began his
career in comedy
when he was out at a bar in south africa
with his cousin and a friend
they were both drunk and began heckling
a comedian that's not true
i wasn't drunk my cousin was on the
other hand and he heckled
the comedian kiribonim laudzi was the
comedian when the comedian challenged
them to come on stage
they sent trevor to perform he went on
stage to avoid looking like a scaredy
cat and discovered that when he spoke
people laughed i don't know if scaredy
cat was the reason i went up i was just
like yeah i'll just go up because i mean
the people
said i wouldn't go up so i went up and
i'm glad i did
thank you again kitty bonnie for doing
that he was a wonderful guy he told me
to try
submit is a huge fan of roller coasters
i am indeed my favorite thing to do on a
roller coaster is ride with somebody who
is the opposite of me
someone who is not a huge fan of roller
coasters
i feel like that is the yin and yang
twitter
[Music]
you may not believe it but it's actually
me trevor noah anyway trevor alright
have you managed to see your family this
year you okay
oh tina you sound really concerned about
me
thank you i've seen my family over
facetime
i uh call my mom actually i call my
brother
and then he gives the phone to my mom
because my mom doesn't do facetime
so i just pop up on my brother's phone
and then she's like ah
what are you doing and then i say hi to
my mom
trevor noah by the way when will your
second book be released
when i have something to say
that trevor noah i know you probably
won't see this but it's driving us nuts
what is that thing over lady liberty's
torch on that sign behind you during the
daily social distancing show
please we need some sleep um
so what is behind me let me think i have
the daily social distancing show behind
me on a screen
it is the statue of liberty lady liberty
is there
she's holding a black lives matter sign
and a riot shield that's what she's
holding a riot shield because what i
started doing was updating the picture
um depending on what was going on in
america and at first i thought it would
be like one thing at a time
but that's not america replied
at trevor noah how cold do you keep your
apartment
and how many hoodies do you own ah the
first question made sense when i read
the second question you're always
wearing one in your daily social
distancing shows
and so many different colors okay how
cold do i keep my apartment
i think the perfect temperature to keep
your house or your car is
22.5 degrees celsius for those who use
numbers that don't exist anywhere else
in the world it is approximately
72 degrees fahrenheit how many hoodies
do i own
i don't count to be honest with you i've
always owned
a lot of hoodies but just because like
that's what i wear at home you know i
feel like a hoodie you know hoodies like
hoodies like a blanket that you wear
just covers you you want you
too cold you know you put your thing up
and then you're not you can pull it down
you can put your hands in like the
pocket thing in the front you know like
a kangaroo
i don't know why everyone doesn't just
wear hoodies instagram
oh boy what games do you play
are you pc ps4 xbox or all of the above
gamer
ms moon i'm all of the above gamer i
play xbox i play a little bit of pc
not that much actually i'm trying to get
into like valorance
and uh i'm trying to get into uh
warzone but on pc which but playing with
a console controller the world is crazy
now
if i'm playing first person shooters i
like to be on xbox and then right now on
ps4 i'm playing ghost of tsushima
korra korra
korra quora
did trevor noah go to college yes
was he supposed to be there because he
was enrolled no
moving on what's a day behind the scenes
at the daily show like
i mean it's just like a group of us we
sit around
and we all read the news and then we all
watch the news and then we make jokes
about the news and then we write about
those jokes and then we write the
serious parts that aren't the jokes
and then we put it all together and then
just like this i speak
to you why does trevor noah always make
fun of spirit airlines i don't make fun
of spirit airlines
spirit airlines makes fun of themselves
i just tell you about it
is the daily show a reasonable way to
get your political news if you only
dedicate 20 minutes a day
huh if you only dedicate 20 minutes a
day to get in your news then yes
the daily show is the best place for you
to get your news because i don't think
there's another place you will get
political news in 20 minutes america is
a very extreme place
either it's 20 minutes or 24 hours
i will give you the shorter version so
you choose
what is in the mugs on the daily show
depends who the guest is
seriously it's actually me
why does trevor noah host of the daily
show mainly target
donald trump why would the host of a
satirical news show
cover donald trump that is a good
question
i guess the question i would ask you is
why
is donald trump the president of the
united states
tough one to answer isn't it no here's
the here's the real answer
uh the daily show covers the president
or what's happening in politics
uh i think it is safe to say that donald
trump is the thing that is happening in
politics
unless i'm wrong am i wrong any anyone
else happening in politics right now
it doesn't matter what story it is by
the way it's donald trump coronavirus
donald trump trade wars donald trump uh
travel restrictions donald trump
uh the middle east donald trump
wildfires donald trump he's involved in
everything he involves himself
himself in everything so i mean the
president of the united states are you
saying i shouldn't speak about the
president of the united states is that
what you're saying
wow wow all right that's it for me
i'm signing off the internet to preserve
my mental health